this is Alexander eater from Bad Homburg
Germany who's about to attach himself to
a train using a special suction cup
designed to transport glass on the
outside of trains the last thing I
expected him to do is to attach himself
to the back of the Train ladies and
gentlemen this is train surfing it's
insanely dangerous and it's your number
5 choice
these are high speed trains this is
really dangerous if this guy falls off
it could be night-night
fortunately Alex lived to tell the tale
so we traveled to Germany to ask him
what inspired the idea I have talked
with a lot of people about it and every
one of them was saying that's impossible
you can't do it the model trains are not
built to surf I had the idea with that
suction pad which is designed to
transport glass yes
these aren't special German train
surfing suction cups so how are they
keeping Alex from falling off a train
capable of 205 mile an hour speeds it's
just big suckers really and what they do
they they suck over the top and then he
pumps first of all and that pumping that
is doing is removing the air from inside
this sucker which creates a vacuum well
he sucks the vacuum there's much less
air pressure out so now you have all the
weight of the atmosphere pushing down on
this disk and so you think that is the
atmosphere it's going to pull him off
because of the wind resistance but what
really is happening is that it's the
atmosphere that's holding him on the
handle itself needs to overcome a couple
forces one the weight of his body and
two the force that the Train produces
when it accelerates for it provided the
air pressure the weight of the air on
that suction padded more than he is he's
gonna be okay assuming the suction pad
stays good Alexander's train surfing
video made a giant splash on the
Internet
clocking over six million views but how
close to disaster did he come
like any other extreme spot a small
probability that you die is over there
but it's perfect